today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block pizza 18:11
Pico Boulevard in Los Angeles and their
sister company bronx-born pizza out in
Bend Oregon gray block and bronx-born
get them hitters
today's guest is uh is a comedian that
has worked harder than any other this
man is uh well actually hell we don't
even really know each other that good
but there's a chance we could get to
know each other better right now in the
next hour he has a new tour out right
now called break the mold he's
everywhere you can get tickets
at Jo koy dot-com ladies and gentlemen
today's guest is jo koy
[Music]
like things that you could do you do
yeah I'm not lying so wait every time
you watch my videos jo koy you always
think of things that I could do like
well just like cuz I'm like so on sore
something like no no no no it's like I'm
always like I don't know if you know
this man but you know we've only talked
a couple times like we've been friends
to the industry and we've always been
like you know like when we saw each
other at the clubs it's like hey Theo
hey Joe yeah I never went really further
than that a couple small talk to things
but like you always reached out to me
yeah like when you went and shot you're
you're special and I always reach out to
you I always get in your head you get in
mine but I just love your hustle and
grind right well so like so I really
enjoy I love watching things that
inspire me and move me forward yeah I
mean so [ __ ] me and there was something
I wanted to say and I just walked on it
it sucks but when you came out with the
animation yeah that character like the
first thing I I said to myself was like
first of all this is a show like this is
the new Simpsons right here whatever
this is is it's [ __ ] amazing your eye
structure whoever that oh yeah accurate
it's beautiful it's [ __ ] beautiful it
should be it should be a stuffed animal
it should be on t-shirts I mean I got
built in vertigo bro right in the
[ __ ] you know in the eyes eyes are
almost even almost but what I love about
that that whole your rants yeah your
60-second rants I almost see in that
either coming to life or even seeing a
live action where you're on stage where
you introduce something with that
animation and then going to stand up
like it's something that you go back and
forth on oh that be interesting show
well one because there's so many people
that are doing that that type of
situation where they're throwing like
Hassan and and I think Chelsea did it
you know I mean and they do that they
use the visual but nothing more original
than yours like it would be just you
doing like your stand up and then boom
you throw it to it gang yeah you don't
mean and then you throw to it just like
how Appel would intro his bit right like
I didn't ya then go to Katt Williams
what inner like introduce a panther into
the [ __ ] or a tiger or a tiger yeah
he was like right in the middle it is
just right in the middle of his joke he
has six [ __ ] holding like holding
holding an urn of some of someone he but
no one questions what's in it but they
know there's something dead in love it
for sure
my mama's in this [ __ ] man he
was great man great are you kidding me
and here's the thing this is what I
don't like about the internet um you
only know the guy that you see that's
getting 15 million views because he's
getting choked out by somebody or he did
something [ __ ] up in Ontario
you know you've all done something [ __ ]
yeah yeah but but no one knows like are
you friends with because I'm friends
with him oh no I'm not friends with him
I wish I was I saw him I saw Katt
Williams one time yeah this is the
craziest thing yeah I was standing on
the front porch of the Comedy Store and
you know sometimes you see people that
have those bikes that have like the
colors lit up in the middle it's like
the lights in him and you're like there
was a group of you know kind of urban
gentlemen driving down the street
together yeah and I looked and in the
main it was back to my buddies Williams
and this is like four years ago
this is hot not literally 30 years ago
and he was a kid this is like there was
just for you know legit gentlemen is
cruising down the street wait are you
telling motorcycles or bicycle bicycles
with those like lit up like it's like
fluorescent as it you know as
electricity going through the some kind
of our piping in the wheels and it's
colorful so you see these and I thought
it was gonna be four you know yeah under
gentleman because it was kind of gay
colors yeah yeah but it was uh for real
deals man yeah yeah on the street yeah
and then you're like that's Katt
Williams I mean you know cat we Louise
he cat Williams yeah and it was Katt
Williams I go way back when he had a
show uh and at a casino and he used to
he'll put me up every now and then this
is way back man we're talking like I'd
have to say sixteen years ago oh yeah it
was someone and I think is he used to go
by Cat in the Hat
oh really yeah I used to go by Cat mahat
my friend have a cat and they named it
Williams Mimi like oh that's cat would
that's pretty cool man but I'm telling
you what the thing about
cat is people don't know how nice the
guy is I've heard amazing things I'm so
nice he adopts all his kids he's got so
many kids and he adopts he was so nice
to me I remember I did BET's coming for
you this is so far back yeah and this is
like I didn't have you were black this
is when I was a black comic before I
became a Latino comic oh yeah it wasn't
like like 11 years when I was like wait
a minute I'm an Asian power and I have a
Filipino mom with a voice hold on by the
end you're Michael Jackson oh my god and
I still did the Apollo and I won how's
that at a black show yeah and then uh
and it was so funny because I I fly into
New Orleans and I forgot where we were
shooting it but I had no agent no man
anywhere there I just bought a plane
ticket it was a black show Black
Entertainment Television so they forgot
that I was even flying in no one picked
me up no bro swear to God oh you know
and I'm standing there with another
comic yeah that was on the show I forget
his name yeah oh my god you know who
else was on that show was uh oh my god
with a straight uh uh wait no stop no
come on
the little Duval was on that Duval this
was his first ever TV appearance real it
was a little Duval like and he was
really little like he was young like he
he earned the name little you know like
17 or some shitty before like it was 46
go Duval be middle-aged Duval you know
be all Duval Duval or elderly elderly
Duval but uh but all I know is I was
standing there and I'm just like I'm
literally homeless bro I had like 150
bucks to my name I'm trying to get to
this hotel I remember saying to myself
maybe I can catch the shuttle I tried to
pick up you know though you know those
phones that show you all the hotels you
pick it up and press the number at the
airport yes that [ __ ] never works
yeah they never [ __ ] work man it
doesn't go to the hotel in a shuttle now
we'll send a shuttle like it's literally
it's usually a woman that sounds like a
could possibly doing it it's somebody do
an impersonation of a black yeah
it is saying Oh we'll send a shuttle
yeah hang up it's a redheaded one white
chick doing the ones that goes through a
Popeye's and they're like uh drive
around and honey what no I want to bed
don't ban in this box of chicken look
how about this we put a UH side item
under your pillow let's call it a night
yo you want the Howard Johnson yeah
Howard Johnson come with a bacon mashed
potatoes yeah come around
what and we don't have them on the menu
but I have a couple of servings right
here in my purse yeah service right here
you couldn't yeah you gonna come around
mother to the next customer what who's
she talking about what you own a bicycle
come on hey does it line up in the
middle yeah don't be embarrassed drive
around here around yeah you want a
gallon to sugar tea yeah don't bring a
gun don't bring a gun don't think we got
good
we got good yeah I'm about to [ __ ] owe
this six piece for the [ __ ] shotgun
about to shoot up this [ __ ] side you
wanna a keg real [ __ ] of John stick yo
what do you want you want a little
Aussie opinion a little woozy fingers
with hot mustard what is that dip the
end it is not gonna Saran way to [ __ ]
blow your brains out
buddy hey I just want to go to bed yeah
you got to go to bed you've read this
Travel I'll pop on this Howard Johnson
[ __ ] this Howard Johnson Denny's
man but I can put syrup on your pillow
[ __ ] yo Grand Slam [ __ ] it's
definitely different in New Orleans it's
so different
so anyways I'm standing outside and cat
pulls up in a limo Wow
it just pulls up like the limo cut well
he doesn't pull up the limo pulls up and
he and he pulls up right behind me and
he's like Jo koy what you doing I'm like
man they forgot they forgot
Semyon man just kidding didn't commie
and I get in the car he drives me we get
to the hotel
of course my rooms not ready no cats is
they got two people smoking in your room
cat got the whole cat got cat got the
13th floor yeah you got nine you got
nine rooms and I'm just trying to wait
for a twin
yeah and mine's not ready and he takes
me out to breakfast yeah like that's the
kind of stuff he does man and he called
you Gary oh and though yeah come on
Henry Cho do Gary Gary Owen introduced
me he needs to come out of the Oise it
bro and that's white people that are
actually black he needs to come out of
the [ __ ] waz it and you know Gary
Owens in there who else is in there
Rosie O'Donnell Rosie O'Donnell yeah
Rosie O'Donnell
yeah she has I you know she has a
Amistad [ __ ] tat on her I've never
seen Rosie O'Donnell yeah she hangs out
at all the black clubs whispers rumours
black clubs always have like a secret
name yeah secret yeah secrets yeah I've
been the secret whispers I've been to
whispers have you ever been to hush-hush
be quiet be quiet
snitches is across no one goes there
snitches are [ __ ] and they get it I
don't go there anymore
nobody gasps yeah the logos like this
the index finger all the lids and it
turns into a musical note around the
hands yeah they do jazz on Wednesdays
that's a nice place huh yeah Courvoisier
oh yeah
Hennessy special yeah oh I got a diving
board on the side the guys up in the
middle of the dance floor
bubbles Wednesday suit me and Anthony
Anderson one time we were doing this um
one of my friends is a referee in the
NBA right yeah so every year he does
this wild event in Norfolk Virginia and
it was it's called like City of Hope or
uh uh if it's about like helping like
single parents right okay so one year
I'm there
Anthony Anderson is their larell is
their and and we all go out one night
right I go out to this club with Anthony
Anderson and it is a urban club this is
in Norfolk okay
and yet Norfolk Virginia okay and and
they is the most like people are dance
and it's a blast and they're people
havin fun I mean people are dancers are
their sweat all over the floor like oh
and there's like probably 500 people
dancing in this capacity sign says 106
oh capacity 100 660 times yes I mean
it's a basketball court
oh it's like Oh what it is or in the day
it is a damn nightclub at night though
and that's going on and somebody ordered
a bunch of fish grilled fish wait hold
on Theo so this is like a gym are you
being serious yeah I'm being serious man
it's like a uh yeah it's like a
community centers okay but it's a
nightclub okay you know and somebody
order your dancing and there's like some
kind of mascot on the dance floor like a
falcon or something yeah right North
Pole there's two cheerleaders that are
[ __ ] don't know what's going on with
all the other games over you why are
they black people why are you so many
black people out here two is on the
course too many black me on the court
foul someone's bowing someone only God
and so I'm scared
she says I'm scared and she is she is
yes I'm scared
and here's the crazy part is so somebody
that's the guy from Romeo Must Die she
only knows she only knows by the movies
easy somebody a menu comes when people
are [ __ ] pop-locking in a menu come
through bro and his Papa like this was
four years ago right the menu bro he was
this big right yeah and there's only two
things on it bro it's written didn't
like a [ __ ] 98 font and what one of
them is fish and one of them is chicken
dude so we order the fish right I'm like
there's no way for $8.50 somebody's
gonna get some fish out to us here on
this dance floor go broke 19 minutes
later a [ __ ] in this blue trach
makes its way over the crowd and it
comes down to us and it is a bunch of uh
fish dicks and grilled fish and fried
fish man and we [ __ ] catfish fillets
that's what it was a partner sighs oh no
no but they had fillets mana tartar was
baked in there the man told us I said
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] don't
have that kind of skills wait a minute
he baked in in fried fish just that brt
baby that baked in tartar and so but
we're sitting there to [ __ ] bra
burning calories pop laughs yeah yeah
I'm [ __ ] earning calories on them
from earning calories and burning talent
and fish for less man oh my and then uh
outside of the place somebody's gonna
shoot the carbon they saw this Anthony
Anderson and didn't do it no you saw him
pull the gun about to shoot this sorry
if you need to get out take a picture
with him and then we like this is a real
story bro this is a real story man
you know those catfish for let's boy and
Anthony remembers and for lets yeah we
ordered a couple orders man and it was
awesome man we had a blast nothing
better than going to a nightclub
basketball court ordering fish bullets
and dance it was awesome
two guys were playing horse and
everybody the whole other place is
[ __ ] good man it was bizarre but it
was awesome man dude you don't even know
why you're here today so what we do when
we started last week it's March Madness
right okay in football season or not
almost love to just continue with the
conversation because it's so great but
it is March Madness and we're in the
second round last week Mr Bryan Callen
was here and he helped us go through the
first round he's a liar by the way Oh
everything that man says is a complete
[ __ ] lie he tested positive he had L
uh he had li e oh yeah yeah and he's got
even that I think is a lie he testifies
refer li e man he was but he's born in
both of his parents were liars
oh well that's right so was it his fault
it isn't his fault now yeah he's a
[ __ ] liar for sure I had a serious
conversation and then when we hung up
you just like you know
is true and then he hung up yeah I love
Brian though i lo I love my I you know
he they work right through this wall
that's where their studio is yeah I love
I love everything about that guy man
when he's 186 oh yeah same ones will be
soon same buddy very severe soon
somebody said he bought a bunch of young
person's a young like a 30 year old
man's hair off the internet like that
old bags in the body
sweaty pretty cool you know what I heard
he got Youngblood yeah like he went to
like Vietnam or something like that and
you get a blood transfusion like dollars
o dollars oh it's and he got my dollar
for blood over there nickel madala
yeah yeah and he got like all the blood
of like a young teenage girl well yeah
keep it so he has estrogen yeah and his
body we started doing the splits the
other day for no reason I was like
what's going on here am I see she was
been a cheerleader yeah she was a
cheerleader dude vietname cheerleader
give me a give me an L give me an air
give me an ow come on give me an air
give me our air what's a sparrow la
Yates has deposited 4li email oh he's
[ __ ] great but not full-blown but
he's got it but what we did is now I
believe that quickly America's headed
towards state governments right yes and
I think it's gonna be helpful in a lot
of areas and some people aren't gonna
like it but whatever man that's America
some people like things and some people
don't and bat and it goes back and forth
yes but we had the first round of if
these states battled each other okay and
and so we're gonna go in and then now
we're in the second round
all right so we need you we you know we
want to educated men who have been
around America yes and who have
experienced America - we're gonna go
through each battle and we're just gonna
get to the next round for us today I
love it
okay yes are you in this I'm in okay
cool and we're gonna use our own why why
each state should pass and we can debate
it and we can argue it and we've got
some fans that are called in and uh Nick
I just want to start I want to pick
we're gonna start them right away but I
want to pick the first one right now
off the bat okay freestyle this one you
ready yeah West Virginia is going all
the way West Virginia is going all the
way to what I don't know whatever the
lab will wait for championship what a
little West Virginia is just my step dad
is from Westbrook okay well they are
they in a battle let's start there then
West Virginia Pennsylvania to verse
seven seed in the East okay this is that
surprise that's you know every every
every March Madness has a surprise just
one it always one that makes it yeah it
always goes one-to-one and then eight
like where the [ __ ] did Harvard come
from yeah so I'm gonna go West Virginia
on this okay why though the stepdad from
there what is he dead yes from there any
skills I don't think he needs any like
this guy is just a man okay he's a man
man that's where that's more from that's
one man what's the population between
those two if you can get figured that us
for snick Pennsylvania brother you're
talking about where a lot of history has
happened here okay you're talking about
Philadelphia I'm talking about coal
miners I'll tell my people that don't
have blood or lungs okay
yeah I'm talking about Philadelphia dog
I don't if you've been to Philadelphia
you've ever been to the mountains of
West Virginia but their mascot is called
a mountaineer [ __ ] [ __ ] really
let's see someone from Philly go up on
those mountains so you're so Philly wet
up the battle uphill what's that
population now Pennsylvania is just
under 13 million and West Virginia is
just under two oh [ __ ] well I mean but
everyone man is considered to be for men
okay million to 13 ok 8 to 13 now
Pennsylvania you got the Quakers out
there you got the Amish Lakers yeah a
Quaker is gonna find a UH a what Oh a
mountaineer okay we're talking about a
man that goes into a tunnel
i lo how many miles underground to dig
coal saying [ __ ] my lungs and each may I
get to canary okay and that's his job
so if this canary dies run wow if the
canary dies run run what kind of man
takes that job not a [ __ ] Quaker okay
not a Quaker but you have a curse or
cursing too much you know you're fine
okay Waker can you wake up with the Sun
bro doesn't even need an alarm clock
imagine that imagine going to bed at
night
and just looking out and out of your
window and tell them the moon to remind
his buddy to get you up first thing
these are two of the stupidest reasons
ever no let me tell you what a coal
miner gives you coal
yeah coal coal which does which what it
tells kid if they're not super - tells
kids they're not have not been good this
year
dude you simons okay see your diamonds
are okay so you're gonna have it you're
gonna have a nice element Pennsylvania
what I'm saying is Quakers can build
what you need you have Philadelphia
they're useless without coal Quakers
don't have coal bro thank you and that's
what the Mountaineer is for and this is
what else I'm trying to get at bro I
don't like oatmeal yeah okay so that'll
like oatmeal and that is the only thing
that a Quaker has ever provided for
anyone today can you I don't ask you
their staff know the runner oatmeal the
runner you tell me what else at Quaker
has provided for America other than
churches do Quakers or good people do
what oh they don't have phones so they
don't have they're not gonna see that
now bro I'm just sayin
oatmeal or coal right but there's so
much more bro you got to go deeper so
West Virginia you have the hills you
have the countryside you're gonna be
able to hide you're gonna have those
Minutemen popping off just thirty
seconds at a time do doubling up but
Pennsylvania have to think you have
Pittsburgh bro you got Jerry Olshansky
out there playing offensive line for
your for your warriors you have big Ben
Roethlisberger shooting deep yeah yeah
you have yep it broke Pittsburgh has
three rivers going Virginia had Randy
Moss Jason Williams major Harris that's
true I'm just saying then those are men
that's three Moss is a man Randy Moss is
a man he's a man man Philadelphia head
through anymore simply uh with a helmet
for like the first time yeah that's true
but his hair was really hard hair was
yeah and they're real corn and those
were real I was real one of the ears of
corn
that's the truth there it is
look at that yeah that's a real helmet
look at that that's it that's a new soft
badge helmet yeah from chips the whole
way chips or tried it we do a TV Center
hot euro tried to Randy Moss cookie I
want to go West Jingyu but PA man they
have okay how about if it goes down to
this you ready mm-hmm logos logos West
Virginia WV WV does it not look scarier
on that helmet then a than an Eagles
wing like really a wing no I'm not I'm
not trying to be funny okay you look at
look at the West Virginia uniform and
then look at an Eagles uniform or even a
Steeler Pennsylvania's Punxsutawney Phil
bro what Punxsutawney Phil who who can
determine the weather with a single jolt
of his neck the uh I don't want you out
again don't ever say that he's not a
racial slur I'm just no I'm just saying
don't tell people you know that
information yeah ever again I won't say
it say man [ __ ] okay can you fight can
thirteen million men from Philly go up a
mountain covered in snow my stepdad
house yeah to dig a hole and this only
reason why he joined the military and
this is a true story because there's
good as [ __ ] you want to hear what he
did yeah he said he was tired of
[ __ ] in the snow hmm he said he ever
hold your [ __ ] with a shovel hmm and hit
the grinder ground so hard that [ __ ]
flies out your ass Wow that's man [ __ ]
yeah so he joined the military because
of that it gets extremely cold also in
Pennsylvania I'm telling you that these
are gonna don't ever say it gets colder
than West Virginia that's two different
things how cold is again in these places
Nick - unbelievable there - 46 yeah but
even if you kill if it 25% of your of
your crew dies off you still are up 6
million people
6 million bodies going to pill at a
certain point enough dead bodies are
gonna make a ladder look at that totals
and averages climb up for West Virginia
is average high average low average
temperature 55.7 can you believe that
that sounds miserable
it's not that cold 50 finally clove 55.8
five see right there 47 degrees is the
average low in both of them it's very
similar man you guys also have a power
grid let's go to the bank here what do
you guys think man let's chime in let's
get naked and we'll get Gianni's in here
people from Philadelphia they burn down
their own city even when they win yeah
and when they win well if they did it
just recently yep
they just right didn't they just do it
recently they probably did they burned
it down they probably turned over turned
over a police Vespa somebody hooked over
a Vespa for no reason beautiful it was
seven gay guys did it apparently yes
they got angry over a Vespa that's awful
but that's I don't they were arrested
even gay guys are rioting - how in
Philadelphia it's change yeah is there
something that interferes with your
happiness or is preventing you from
achieving your goals
if so better help online counseling is
there for you better help offers
licensed professional counselors who are
specialized in issues such as depression
stress anxiety anger grief self-esteem
and more connect with your professional
counselor in a safe and private online
environment anything you share is
confidential and it's so convenient get
help at your own time and at your own
pace you can schedule secure video or
phone sessions plus chat and text with
your therapist if you're not happy with
your counselor you can request a new one
at any time best of all it's a truly
affordable option and this past weekend
listeners get 10% off your first month
with discount code Theo von no spaces th
EO vo in I've tried better help and it
worked for me it was an opportunity
where I could you know talk with a
therapist on my phone FaceTime Skype or
even text and and one time I was even in
my car and I needed somebody to talk to
and I was able to access my better help
therapist so why not get started today
if you need help and you're not able to
get it and you want to try a new avenue
go to better help calm slash Theo von
simply fill out a questionnaire to help
them assess your needs and get matched
with a counselor you'll love that's
that are help.com slash Theo von what
else I'm definitely going Pennsylvania I
lived there for a year like around
wilkes-barre area and it was really I
thought that doesn't that means that
we'll live for a year and there's my
there's miners in Pennsylvania as well
as there's a huge coal mine there's also
huge drive-by shooting community in
Philadelphia they're not but uh wow this
is oh I won no you didn't win we're
gonna go to the fans on this one we're
gonna go there'll be a tiebreaker if you
two disagree the poll be the tiebreaker
and there it is
53% go West Virginia I told you a 47%
cuz if somebody doesn't know what a
hundred percent is and that's 47 percent
from Pennsylvania West Virginia moving
on wow that's a low spin that was fun
very close that's where that was for you
dad I thought you two are gonna step dad
he's my dad dad well he's my stepdad but
that's my dad well bring the
documentation next time you all right
well I'm joking thank you Dan yeah loves
his name Frederick Harrison Frederick
Harrison Sarge Roderick Harrison Wow
Harrison he sounds like a colonel he
sounds like he's from Pennsylvania yeah
your son of a [ __ ] don't disrespect my
father like to have I'm sorry my
stepfather I'm sorry mr. Harrison and
thank you for raising such a nice boy
you know what he would call you Bubba
woody he would call you Bob I want to
[ __ ] split a piece of pie with that
guy alright look at this white guy
cobbler we're new another battle here
where we at net new jiaying in the East
New Jersey versus Rhode Island face the
winner faces West Virginia and we have a
video sent in here from someone homeward
man that was a close one that West
Virginia Philly I'm glad I won New
Jersey would win because we don't give
up
[Music]
wow wow very adamant that young man
adamant uh I'm not a fan of people that
try and dye their hair blonde and it
just gets yellow that didn't look
natural blonde yeah no so he does give a
[ __ ] is the thing if he's dying his hair
yeah see right there like he what
happened is he
there's two things that happen one he
ran out of money to keep stripping the
color out because it costs a lot of
money to get it down to platinum blonde
right yeah like [ __ ] it man I'm about 50
bucks in I'm good or to his scalp
started burning and he was like [ __ ]
this this hurts
which makes him a [ __ ] and there's no
way you can win
what does no way you can win what if he
just wanted to keep up with his buddies
and every in the neighborhood dyed their
hair I mean it is [ __ ] New Jersey you
know these are people that still do
wrestling in their backyard I have a
friend he won $10,000 on the prices
right he bought a wrestling ring for his
back oh and then he told everybody in
the neighborhood not joking he told
everybody that everybody got ACDC to
come perform there at a party and and
then they didn't and everybody came for
the party and I couldn't ban didn't come
he told her where they [ __ ] flake
pretty swab move but he's still got laid
though and he still scored a couple of
vials of tests some kind of TV show this
kid won $10,000 I bought a rest and that
kid was Vince McMahon that's how it
works these are good people over there
these are Bruce Springsteen and Hacksaw
Jim Duggan fans of their new jersey bro
a lot of self tanner
a lot of young men touching their own
bodies with different colored eyes no
pigments in their head a lot of lined up
hairstyles oh yeah a lot of lined up
very it's very lined up you know I mean
a lot of math out a [ __ ] head
calculator head calculus a lot of gel
hard hard hard Joe yeah yeah hard oh
definitely yeah a lot of oh my god
there's a lot of milk carrots steroids a
milk still yeah hormones and everything
there's hormones in your buddy there's
home ones in the cattle yeah is this
Jersey as well it's uh no I think he's
going for the other side for Rhode
Island let's hear what this young man
said he's wearing a gold chain it's good
views is Christian from Prague
Rhode Island um I want to talk about the
around versus New Jersey matchup I think
we take this one easily to be honest
Rhode Island man were small but you know
we still got those connections like we
got the real Italians in this state if
you know what I mean and I think you
know what I mean down the I think at the
Jersey Shore they got the [ __ ] in gym
tan laundry they tend to much they got
that skin cancer unfortunately they got
those stick legs we take them out by the
[ __ ] knees like it's no problem and
an add minutes to invade our state I
know it's small you can invade our state
the roads are too [ __ ] shitty you
can't even drive on our roads so what
are you gonna do we can send our said
all day where you guys Rob you guys just
keep piling up your cars and we'll just
plow you out
we got the artillery baby wow you were
this was well thought out he makes a
great case for Rhode Island is it a real
island or not Johnny's from there let's
go to Jionni on this piece no it's not a
real island but it is on the coast
[ __ ] straight answer without you [ __ ]
now media well you're a liar there's not
a real island you grew up on a lie yeah
he's a liar and a head shitty roads so
like that guy just told us so it's not a
real ly ly because it's that's crazy cuz
we sit on the coast yeah and we're not
annoying
yeah we're not Los Angeles Island yeah
we could be we could be so it's whoever
the cartographers are a real [ __ ] oh
yeah bro that's what I'm sayin I'm gonna
go with this guy I like Rhode Island
Jersey's big good you know how big your
Jersey's big jersey big but here's the
thing about Jersey all right well you
just make a left on New York you see
shitty Jersey off to your right yet I
mean well you just make a left there
but Newark dude you've Hoboken bra a lot
of grilled bread over there I ain't
think of that you know a Jersey you got
Millikin University out there somewhere
dude there's Trenton New Jersey nobody
has ever even been there oh I just like
the word Trent oh you got people doing
Bible study in their basement man you
got a lot of women doing making you know
makeshift hair salons in the kitchen
during the daytime yeah they have been
keep it that's one thing about Jersey
they have been
the women have been keeping the 90s
bouffant hair alive that is dead
everywhere else in this country dude
yeah but in in Jersey it's it's at least
four inches away from their head you got
yeah oh definitely four inches away from
the head jersey man you got it if your
hair is close to your skull in Jersey
you're a [ __ ] yeah yeah they call you
[ __ ]
yeah hope they say that yeah hah yeah
hah yeah hah yeah and a lot of Muslim a
large Muslim community - over there in
New Jersey limbs a lot of people call
him slim Slim's but a lot of beautiful
Muslim can meet Camden has been ranked
go ahead now Camden has been ranked
among the most dangerous cities in the
United States in 2002 2004 2005 and 2009
Wow
they don't want to bring like the Pats
and what about Providence oh is
Providence dangerous Providence
Providence no you cannot aim like
Providence there's like there's like a
two three mile radius that's dangerous
in South Providence the commuter violent
or property crime Providence is one in
26 well you know what man the chance of
becoming a victim of violent or property
crime in Providence is 1 in 26 what is
it in New Jersey I wonder it's one in
four you know what's crazy about that
video that was sent in as you did a
great job he did a great job he well
thought out to go for the knees to go
for the legs but he still didn't scare
me really you know I mean like the guy
with the the bleached hair he scared me
who bleachy yeah bleachy but yeah
Ponyboy Curt
Ponyboy what do we got there Nick
anything not for the let's see the pole
well the pole is I can be fair because
there's more people in one state than
the other so I don't know we can go to
the pole I mean all of them are like
that but this one is blatantly but
you're saying everybody voted for
everyone wait wait wait wait like
there's the same amount vote so it's not
necessarily people from those states
voting yeah I think I mean Rulon you're
gonna get to the wall yeah I don't mean
to interrupt you I don't want your
showed I don't want to disrespect you
you know your show but did you really
think the whole state
voted or did you think it was just out
like out of a hundred people cuz I I
thought as many people that voted as
could in the state like as many fans
that we had that are from New Jersey
voted it's no I don't think there's any
poll yes yeah that's no pull
yeah so I'm not really a good polar but
I'm a pole lock so what do we can New
Jersey Rhode Island I'm gonna go my gut
here tells me Jersey yeah I'm gonna go
Jersey I wasn't at first but I wasn't
either cuz that God did a great argument
yeah that's a good matchup right there
versus access to the water but I can too
and there's a lot of military bases in
Newport farther yeah we're good we're
good we're good
yeah we're Jersey New Jersey with
Newport is also maybe at the Marines
Newports also a cigarette dude Oh
done yeah you're out who mostly smokes
Newports if you really think about
people from Newport people from Newport
New Jersey well I'm Philadelphia all
right let's rock out this next one this
one is gonna be Nick Massachusetts first
Maryland whoa we got a video from again
what up do is Austin from Brockton
Massachusetts Boston home of Rocky
Marciano Marvin Hagler - unbelievable
fighters and to start off I mean
Massachusetts fighters I mean listen you
go to Boston you're gonna get some
creatures from Southie just looking at
you just wanting to fight you for no
reason I mean we're aggressive not gonna
lie when you think about it this way -
we colonized America that's some hard
[ __ ] to do not a lot of people have the
guts for that I mean outside of that I
just passed by a Dunkin Donuts we're
load up on the cards will be ready for
battle and think about a Maryland look
at the name Mariel and a bunch of Mary's
over there they don't have a chance
think getting buzz buzz man Wow some
really good input here man it's amazing
we got a great group of people sending
in videos thank you right there
Massachusetts verse Maryland now Marilyn
I'm gonna go out and say here you have
Annapolis
yeah but are they gonna fight here's my
question for you jo koy would a military
fight for where they are or fight for
where they're from because those people
are all gonna be from different places
that's true I just like UMass
I've always liked UMass whenever I love
UMass oh yeah Marcus Camby came from
UMass oh yeah got their uniforms Oh a
lot of amazing men a lot of freaking
amazing you know I was just going to
college teams yeah yeah you're right
right Massachusetts remember
Massachusetts from history books
Massachusetts no one ever knew how to
spell it
yeah confusing half way until dough now
smile I'll try you try ma SS a uch I PPI
yeah dude it's Mississippi's dirty
little sister you're filming so I'm
saying this right there Massachusetts
man they got a lot of history after
working stuff I like the fact that you
can say UMass yeah that just sounds
aggress my asshole's they call the bass
hole but Maryland man you're talking to
Napa listen I got to go back to the
question would a military fight for
where they're from or fight for the
place they're stationed they would fight
they will fight no matter what it's
their job right yeah they have to or
they go to jail right but are they going
to fight for where they're from or we
have a Maryland guy yeah let's hear him
alright Maryland went to war
Massachusetts rise over trying to tell
me them [ __ ] city headers and
Baltimore [ __ ] City
I'm city folk are gonna lose an awards
people from Massachusetts brah you've
seen us right we [ __ ] our whole city
up bro we burn that [ __ ] down wrong I'm
gonna lose the [ __ ] Massachusetts
boom whoa Gang Gang let me get a game
okay this guy I totally bald I forgot
about Cal Ripken jr. one other baseball
player played into his 70s yeah and
still hit homers and that's a man dude
and also the opioid epidemic I don't
know if you noticed or not but they are
are starting five million live in
Baltimore dude
yo bro it is zombie nation dude if you
ever want to fight if you like the
walking dead yes bro you'll love
Baltimore dude there are people just
like this just on the Bernie you know
not in the morning Sanders the weekend
up man we can turn e man they look like
they're just being held up by strings oh
just like a blind guy just chasing a
rain cloud oh losing their [ __ ] that's
the Baltimore yeah let's go oh it's on
quick but that's it the hill came from
Baltimore he did Dru Hill well that's a
group but they did oh yeah yeah well
look ma'am but Baltimore also dude they
let's go the drink no Cisco the lead
singer of Dru Hill blacked out with the
blonde
Viennese evil love that song oh don't
don't
yeah Wow it's fun being racist in here
today I must say this man I think I got
to go mass because Baltimore is just too
opioid it out man god bless the military
over there in Annapolis but I think
those bad boys if [ __ ] hits the fan
they're gonna go fight for their
homelands more than they are gonna fight
just because they're all in school
together
but then also they are a tribe and they
fight together a lot of those times but
they may partner off and then go fight
for their home states that's nothing
that we do I'm gonna go Baltimore okay
Maryland that guy put up a strong point
I totally forgot about the city folk
yeah I am gonna go for the zombies you
know how hard is a knock off a [ __ ]
zombie did you see what Brad Pitt did in
World War Z did you see that took
forever to do it but ya know it's hard I
agree what let's go to unless you wrap
yourselves up in phone books and fight
these [ __ ] zombies you're not gonna
win well look there's way many extra
phone books so they could do that
probably yeah let's go to the tale of
the tape MIT Massachusetts with 64% to
36% Massachusetts breaks the tie between
Joe and Theo they move on game s juice
moves on I'm sorry bro alright we got a
real hitter right here we get that
really heater New York versus so this is
between us man I'm gonna
I'm gonna start with Maine you have a
lot of a lot of people rolling and in
Volkswagens forgetting why they drive
Din to the city even probably because
they're so high yeah a lot of people out
there angry because everybody's doing
home crops a weed and now it's become
more commercialized you got a lot of
Grateful Dead fans you got a lot of just
dead people you got a lot of mystery a
lot of graveyard the ocean I think a lot
of people that die in New York get
buried in Maine oh yeah I could see that
I see that that's a lot of burial ground
like there's a lot of land to bury the
yeah you got Islesboro island you got a
lot of rich people living out off the
coast who I think we're probably enough
fending for themselves before they would
for their state you know I think the
main the main people you're gonna get
that are gonna rock there gonna be some
[ __ ] you know some badass lesbians
out of Camden right there on the coast
you're gonna have what's that airport
but the airport in Maine bum bar Bangor
Bangor and you know Bangor what is it
like so it sounds like a [ __ ]
character from like Winnie the Pooh that
never got it never made it yeah you know
you're spangled and a Jaguar yeah that's
a Bangor now that sounds [ __ ] Patman
that's scary I was thinking more like
Eeyore is like mentally troubled brother
Bangor Oh bang where's my tail you know
ask you another question
Oh wish I had some money I could get
some candy calm down Bangor hey what's
this thing between my legs okay I'm
gonna leave stupid
okay so you got mad now New York they're
way too gentrified in the cities from
Manhattan take a [ __ ] man hike bro
yeah they got way it's way it's bunch of
[ __ ] rich white people don't place
you can even get [ __ ] mugged or two
nuts touches over there in Alphabet City
yeah down there on B and 12th you know
I've never been there
you haven't nope never been aware being
twelfth Alphabet City New York City have
ever been there go down there it's the
last that a real seed you can get
[ __ ] mugged you can learn Spanish
it's good
oh that's from Joey Diaz direct I
literally stay in two areas and that's
it yeah mid-city man is Soho yeah
that's that's all that's all I do it's
all it is man so in a lot of the rete
you know like the real hitters though
out of New York I'm talking Rochester
brother talking now buddy I'm talking
[ __ ] Rochester Syracuse neck tattoo
country so yeah no I'm saying I want
income Orangeman oh yeah that the worst
[ __ ] mascot name of all time the
Orangemen yeah I'd be a real man to have
a name like that you got to be real men
and wear orange is still [ __ ] hot
from people yes and that's what they're
doing up there they're doing good I'm
going New York State all the way sorry
main that makes sense
they're juggernaut the one seed all
right let's move to the south first
matchup Florida over South Carolina
that's tough man I've been to South
Carolina man and what happened those are
some real people I that's my first time
I'm not really I'm not gonna make this
up man okay this is gonna sound like I'm
making this the frosting belt a lot of
frosting of it bro I'm just saying I've
never seen overalls on a white man
before until I played South Carolina and
that is a true story that shirt overalls
and a dad hat Oh from the Boca sparks
boutique brother 105 and he said I love
you and that was funny yeah and I and I
believed everything that came out of his
mouth and that was a real dude right
there it's limited word belt though ya
know here was it won't let me see it
again
yeah I I loved it and I love you that's
it yeah yeah
we're talking about people that [ __ ] on
the 4th of July man I'm talking about
real Americans over there yeah over here
in South Carroll a cup man I love South
Carroll Acme to break your shirt off
spin around your head and that's North
Carolina but ever who put it wherever
row looks and on Jeep I can get lost for
you driving the table low oh he sat on
the border of North Carolina south ok he
claimed a bolt take your shirt off a
ball let's here we got it we got a video
that came in here South Carolina
deserves to win it all based on one
thing that is the Anderson jockey lot
this is a big patch of land that exists
in Anderson South Carolina where on
Saturdays people come at like 4:00 or
5:00 in the morning they set up a table
and they just sell [ __ ] on the free
market you can go there and you can get
diabetics
one VHS out of the box set from Titanic
well unregistered guns a Bop it peaches
for a second regardless of your race
color creed background beliefs you come
to the jockey lot you stand across the
table you are just a human being
offering not enough for said product and
it's a beautiful thing in South Carolina
and gang baby Wyatt Anderson lot he's
talking about he's talking about peaches
and a boPET that's funny man I like how
he said unregistered gun yeah and then
he went and beaches look you gotta have
something to shoot with the gun yeah and
that boPET that's exercise right there
so South Carolina it's coming in now I
will say this you have Wofford you have
the Citadel and the Citadel's were a lot
of military trains and it's young men so
they may be - under the influence -
really - whatever it's called go AWOL
and go back to their hometowns they may
be still a little bit brainwashed you
know god bless them but you know I've
seen a march through the streets of
Charleston South Carolina and they stay
in line those young boys yeah and so
you're gonna get that in South Carolina
you got Clemson you got what's-his-name
the quarterback over there a Dabo
Swinney run it so he's gonna be coaching
your troops man is the coach man but now
Florida take me in to Florida brother ah
the Gators man Gator country right don't
they don't they don't they get every
there like a farm were you from Florida
no you from there Northwest yeah I'm
from the Northwest but you could look
like you are from Florida well that's
not a but you'll fit in easier buddy all
right so let's go to this big whitey
that sent this in yo what up Theo I'm RJ
I'm from Florida and I wanted to talk to
you about Florida versus South Carolina
bro there's no chance in hell a [ __ ]
South Carolina is gonna win Florida well
we're both equally as racist but Florida
has one secret weapon bro bath salts
that's all we need to win
get those bath salts ambiance out
Carolyn's ass it's all over bro 100%
gang gang thank you RJ and I love how
now that's Florida right there it's a
little secret if he didn't even give us
full name bro RJ okay he didn't even
spot us a [ __ ] vowel
Robert Johnson what is it yeah it could
be [ __ ] Randall Jones ruff Randall
Jones man ah could be racist Johnson I
be in a rut I can't trust a guy that has
a full beard and still has a baby stache
yeah that's a little scary right there
uh he has a Kardashian voice mm-hmm
that's not I don't trust that I'm just
saying I'm just saying those two things
right there alone I'm not scared South
Carolina I'm a little scared are you
yeah man those are real dudes that that
little belt right there some real men
there man yeah they practice well you
got a lot of people from Jersey you got
a lot of people in New York that retired
yeah they're [ __ ] they got cancer all
over the bike it's just like they're
ready to die yeah that's true now
Florida you gonna have a lot of people
that suddenly when it gets it when it's
when the [ __ ] Americans [ __ ] hit the
fan yeah they're gonna leave they head
back home look everybody suddenly yeah
they're gonna go first yeah well you
know what Cuba comes over like this
[ __ ] makeshift boat made out of like
a old car no you're gonna have boats
going the other way when [ __ ] hits the
fan
oh you mean we're gonna leave people are
going to yeah like if somebody's here
and they're like yeah like if they're
just here like you know kind of
profiting in the country yeah they're
gonna be out that you know do you think
some refugee that a refugee for another
country is going to fight for this
country now they may but do you think
that they would or not maybe they would
maybe I would wouldn't I think Nick I
think Florida's got a lot of old people
so I mean they're just they may have
more population but they're all about to
die any what's target practice yeah yeah
you can have a lot of yeah you also have
a lot of Jewish on they don't fight you
don't see a you and well they work it
out though but they work it out but you
still all the time the courts are gonna
be packed you know they're gonna be all
done at the courthouse yeah yeah so on a
legal battle Baddeley a lot of
infighting a lot of yes a lot of zoning
and servitude issues being filed yeah so
but then also man Florida dude you got
the first 48 bro in the first 48 hundred
episodes of that show we're filmed that
in Florida bro your work you don't get
murdered in Miami you're nobody yeah you
nobody that's true so you got Miami then
all their football teams were just thugs
yeah they all about his prison time
FAU University of Florida that some guys
tim tebow they had the Lord down there
for a while and stuff man this is a
tough one bro Wow yeah landslide damn I
think people are really Florida is known
for being crazy they're the wild card
that's true
67 percent says Lotus crazy they selling
pirates and Tampa like you're messing
with a lot of different cultures row so
that's the thing you didn't be fighting
so many groups there that could be it
might not be as unified them and you get
up to Tallahassee and that's just
Georgia [ __ ] Yeah right itself yeah
[ __ ] though bro Jacksonville yo it's
a robe Duval County yeah they're crazy
yeah you're right no I'll still go with
Florida yeah I'll go Florida Dade County
to where Kimbo Slice is training people
in this backyard yeah Jorge mas a lot of
people died in those videos that's one
thing you don't know about that yeah
yeah not surprised Florida man come here
die here YouTube page the strongest
survived yeah other praised lower
brother today's episode is also brought
to you by skill share skill share it's
an online learning community for
creators are you a creator are you
creative do you want to expound on that
you want to learn what some of your real
creative sensibilities are skills share
can help with more than 25,000 classes
in design business and more you'll
discover countless ways to fuel your
curiosity creativity and career take
classes in social media marketing mobile
photography creative writing or even
illustration whether you're looking to
discover a new passion start a side
hustle or gain new professional skills
skills share is there to keep you
learning thriving and reaching those new
goals join the millions of students
already learning on Skillshare today
with a special offer just for my
listeners our listeners get two months
of Skillshare for free that's right
Skillshare is offering this past weekend
listeners two months of unlimited access
to over 25,000 classes for free to sign
up go to Skillshare dot-com slash Theo
von again go to
he'll share calm / Theo von to start
your two months now
that's Skillshare dot-com / t heo vo n
get them skills Georgia versus Alabama
have you ever been Alabama yes
you got Nick Saban right they're one of
the greatest leaders of our time I mean
he is basically he's the [ __ ] he's a
George Washington of the south really
yeah what does that the Crimson Tide
yeah I know what that is now Alabama
also you have this red clay you got a
lot of red clay up there you have a lot
of tornadoes yeah Georgie you got
Atlanta you got a hot Lana yeah you got
hot and it is hot it is hot you got off
set up at the front running your troops
yeah you know and he seemed like a real
[ __ ] I saw him and that uh I saw him
playing the celebrity basketball game
how do you do uh and I thought it was
somebody from the WNBA ooh
you know like the six-man yeah oh not
even starting yeah Latrell Sprewell
little cousin Oh horrible
yeah oh we got some input right here
from one of our listeners onward you
know Theo von
what's up out here at work I think if
any stay where win the war it would be
Georgia because they have a bunch of
crazy rednecks with guns
and a bunch of crazy black people
against everything against black people
but they get crazy and that guy was
black and white so I wanna I want to let
everybody know that all who just listen
to an audio that was a mixed gentleman
they used to call him that and now they
still call him man yeah there's two man
mix you know young man and he was
working an electric wire so obviously
that guy's been up in a on a boom lift
he's seen what's going on he can see the
landscape see the landscape he knows
what he's working with he's also doing
that on company time yeah and you gotta
respect that and I respect that so he's
listed to feel very Georgia and yeah and
just not giving a [ __ ] about his job
that's both very Georgia and Alabama
dude do another stuff on company time
wow this is a tough one yeah this is
tough I I love Birmingham but that's all
you got
I remember when I played Tuscaloosa yeah
I did a joke on one of my specials about
Alabama because I did a this one I was
doing the college tour and this one the
student picks you up from the you know I
mean when they pick you up from the
airport and drive you to the to the
college and the first question he asked
because it was I did BET's comicview and
he goes he goes so man how is it on that
TV show
he thought I was on that show always
always yeah and then that's when I was I
unbelievable [ __ ] man this really lives
out here yeah people have different
ideas there are a lot of people they
don't watch as much television they're
not on the internet as much like it's a
little different it's a different
environment man you get down into the
like into the middle of America and into
the south it's like so what you think
you live in the TV set yeah
oh the other day I was talking to my
folks back home and they're like yeah
willing grace uh
you know have you seen what they're up
to like very bizarre Wow and you didn't
really yeah you know it's two different
worlds you know but look man beautiful
states some of the top football players
in the nation
I'm gonna go gorge on this because you
do have Atlanta you have the hill
country to Co up there in North Georgia
a lot of Indians out there yeah you got
a lot of Indians out a lot of Indians
man and they're still there going
yeah they're still living there I think
they'll fight - oh yeah though fight
right such interesting states because
but Georgia has Atlanta and Atlanta's
Georgia Tech you have Emory University
you're gonna come up with some more
educated you know technical engineers
I'm in Iraq with Georgia guy Ted Turner
- he's insane and Young Jeezy Oh Georgia
Chipper Jones yeah how how can you not
be scared of a guy named chipper yeah
he's [ __ ] Sheppard oh yeah bro he
played into his 50s he would eat his bad
it is bad if you got a home run he used
to fight it in half I saw him do it live
yep let's go to the people what they say
on this one Nicholas
they said Alabama 54% Wow that's enough
margin for error
George Georgia gets it yeah it's no
margin for error and yeah people get a
dog man the B dog huh yeah and we might
only make it through half today huh can
you tell me what a Crimson Tide is
please is it an elephant
it's a menstrual cycle on her and that
[ __ ] beats everybody uh-oh okay
that's a stupid miss guy yeah Georgia
Bulldogs what I got oh I thought I was a
baby for a second
next up Nicholas we got number four
oklahoma verse number five Virginia Wow
Virginia's got a lot of very amazing
producers came out of Virginia mm-hmm
I'm a song like go vegetables and fruits
you mean no no like singers man like
like like Pharrell Chad Hugo Teddy Riley
Timbaland like a lot of those producing
Aaron Brooks do one of the water backs
ever for the New Orleans Saints well I
met at a buffet one time and he didn't
know like kind of how a buffet worked
which was that howling dude I've never
met anybody who didn't know something
like that but he was the happy I start
in the middle and then work my way
either left or a called a 20-second
timeout at all a timeout
yeah but he was the nicest man I've ever
met man but uh this is a tall
one man do we have any videos here net
we do what's cracking man is Big Brother
over here in Oklahoma beginning me and
I'm out chair and I just want to say I'm
weighing in on a Virginia versus
Oklahoma and I just want to say we're
beat they [ __ ] ass any day you know
how to mean I might not think ain't no
brothers down here in Oklahoma but we
down here and we're deep and we're thick
you know I mean look at these cheeks
bite somebody from love a gene and this
and that's all my mama right now so I'm
just saying it right now yeah okay gang
boys big be out there get on the front
lines boy Bo weapons brothers brush your
teeth and [ __ ] get out there my god
he said daddy my guy said look at these
cheeks
yeah and right there right there you
should be scared so on that picked a
body part that no one uses yeah in any
fighting situation and he did yeah
forget it
oh is that a big squirrel over here not
a co ass boy
but to get snack pattern and that's
Oklahoma now we'll say this about
Oklahoma man these are people out there
these are white people a lot of them
that defeated Native Americans yes you
have a lot of Native Americans that are
you know have anger so they would love
to go attack someone else I'm gonna get
a little bit of a revenge
the last hairstyle that was famous aside
from yours was Brian Bosworth and that
came out of Oklahoma yeah he had that
the Brian Bosworth and Ryan Bosworth
right there Lyle Alzado is little buddy
Oh Lyle Alzado is little buddy that's
right yup and uh Oklahoma Abby what is a
[ __ ] sooner it's better than later
brother gonna get it done right now get
in there sooner not later
well the feel Vaughn is what he called
it back then then called that the Theo
no knew what the [ __ ] start work cuz
The Cosby Show is hot back there that
Brian Bob yeah that's that Brian
Bosworth there blew his shoulder out his
first season when he got ran over
blob Oh Jackson but that's okay and then
we call Seattle 150-million and then he
blew it right back in look right bat was
[ __ ] buying Bosworth
now Virginia dude now Virginia oh we got
something Oh what's up the Oh what's up
Joe this is Zack from Virginia Virginia
versus Oklahoma Virginia vs. anybody is
no contest not only do we got CIA
headquarters all the government stuff
I mean DC's basically Virginia it's
definitely not Maryland we got tunnels
from the White House to places in
Virginia all the way down
we got the Pentagon we basically got the
smartest people in the country here we
also got all the southern people guns so
many [ __ ] Walmart so down here so
many pregnant ladies would dip in their
mouths I mean they're ready to strike
the thing people forget about or how
many gangbangers we got out here we got
the fourth largest ms-13 population in
all of America's Virginia not DC just
Virginia and we got the third largest
military presence in any state is
Virginia check that facts on just Google
- [ __ ] bro you went out for like two and
a half minutes wow man yeah that that
that video right there it looked like he
was calling from somewhere scary that's
not a wall that you have in your house
no he's kidnapped yeah he's definitely
kidnapped there's definitely a gun being
pointed at him right now
yeah probably by somebody in Virginia
snowing in Virginia so you know they're
ready yeah say this to [ __ ]
keep reading [ __ ] all the way down
we got two minutes work - [ __ ]
[ __ ]
keep reading write it I called a white
boy white boy yeah read this read this -
keep googling
you got a love this young stand bribe
you know what I'm saying about a guy I
like I like his argument I didn't know
they had tunnels do my buddy Lance
Hecker's a Navy SEAL based out of there
I forgot about that Newport News is over
there you got Norfolk you have some of
the wildest high school and Division two
and three college football in America in
Virginia a lot of amazing athletes come
out of Virginia you do have a huge
military presence you have every single
for us there you got the Coast Guard
which no one gives a [ __ ] about yeah
there too you even have ROTC do which is
just kids at after high school grade
five don't they fight oh yeah I was in
the ROTC where you got really huge
[ __ ] fight with who did goddamn [ __ ]
yeah right in front of a Safeway Oh beat
the [ __ ] out of these dudes they walked
by is that their [ __ ] anger just
around their necks
bro we took our caps off with in went
[ __ ] it in we have patent leather shoes
on man course you dress up once either
pom pom yourself and wax
they're already patent leather man we
didn't beat the [ __ ] out of these kids
okay that's a high gang
high-tech [ __ ] whatever hiking boots
high-tech low-tech and also Virginia
when you least expected an order from
[ __ ] fish fillets or roll right in a
[ __ ] feed the troops I'm gonna rock
with Virginia on this what I'm gonna go
with Virginia too sir beautiful sweet
one more match up in the south what do
we have the people celebrated Nick sorry
51% to 49% for Jin right on the fence
there it's crazy
Wow that's how you know we're at the
cream of the crop when the votes are
that close what's going in with a girl
on her period an older woman that's at
least called Bush cool what else we got
here man that's what they call it they
use called a push bush-gore get that
Bush go okay you know yeah do the worst
when you get that Mitt Romney dog what's
that oh that I don't know that's me
shoot you in the head sounds better
still your friend yeah it sounds
questionable Nicholas last matchup in
the south we got number one Texas first
Theos home state of Louisiana how do you
say it correctly though Louisiana so
that's the way you say Louisiana
Louisiana now some people say Louisiana
that's what I thought Louisiana yeah
some people say New Orleans some say no
yeah how do you say I say New Orleans
New Orleans I'm in the middle I say
Louisiana
it's a Louisiana yeah I got owed our
cars to our gang gang baby right there
beautiful Viet let's go it's Alex from
Houston Texas and I gotta say man I'm
probably not the first one to say it
probably was just only a matter of time
but I think that in the event of an
uprising Texas would most likely win
because we probably have the most people
per capita armed and prepared for
conflict and defense a man boy that's
all you needed and I believe that was an
illegal video are you sure he was
arrested soon after look thank you Alex
for sending in that video man Wow and
that guy is all about it bro Latino or
Viet man right that was a Viet man for
sure was up there was something there I
don't know what for sure he's not Latino
that for 100% he's only 14 his body's 36
for sure he is Jack brother this guy
yoked there's a lot of kimchi a lot of
rice yeah I think we also take another
poll and figure out which type of Asian
he is I'm gonna say Korean if we could
have him nick is there anything we can
reach out to or DMM or something and I
would go Korean I'm gonna say Korea I
would say hearty Korean though I already
say Nick Korea his mom has thick song
and maybe Tong and no rien nope Tong it
he's not no he's not down there at all
but I believe he's definitely in Asia
for sure yeah he's a shipping baby dude
somebody met on yeah that is a that is a
big boy that's what they call a big boy
that's what they call a big boy big boy
big boy there big boy boy yeah big boy
big boy big boy bob's big boy
bob's big okay I'm gonna say this my
actually my step-brother sent me in a
couple of things from Texas I'm gonna
say two before I get into my state of
Louisiana I'm gonna read these right
here he said some things for Texas he
said as it relates to the March Madness
state wars every man woman and child in
Texas are heavily armed he went on to
say with a ridiculous amount of ammo we
have strategic ports they have Corpus
Christi dune it's a lot of people
smoking weed down there let's be honest
about that time all right Mexico would
back the great Republic so we have
endless troops our proposal to them to
get them to fight serve and you have
residency done deal done they're in they
are in no problem
we're already there yeah [ __ ] we will
let y'all got bullets okay we have the
oil all wars are won in laws based on
fossil fuels to treat strategic reserves
and having the diesel and jet fuel to
power their fleet we produce over four
million barrels a day
we've got Willie Nelson and then I'm
gonna say limited time only I'm gonna
say a limited time only oh yeah Willie's
get know yeah you know they have
breakfast tacos
they have expansive terrain that most
soft-shoe liberals would never dare step
foot on they have 18 military
installations can I add yeah they also
invented tex-mex mmm and that's the best
kind of Mexican food tex-mex and that's
worldwide now yeah tex-mex
that's true and very welcoming too huh
it is hey your food our food gang yeah
livestock and textiles we have zero
issues feeding clothing and turning the
industrial powerhouse into into
overdrive wealth we have sovereign money
they also have unlimited land I mean
they are huge
yeah who's bigger than Texas in land
who's bigger in heart I'll tell you
right now Louisiana baby okay Louisiana
you're talking about can't fight a war
with heart bro okay I've seen that many
times but dude yeah but some of the
gumbo that they have over there bro they
they actually does another word for it
gumbo oh and sometimes people will have
a bowl up at a big bowling in their
local little [ __ ] 38 pull that [ __ ]
Master P do that one of his movies oh
yeah the gumbo special he pulled out he
it looked like gumbo yeah then he pulled
out a [ __ ] a are ya just destroyed the
place a lot of missing spouses in
Louisiana a lot of people go a lot of
dead bodies fine along the interstate so
people are ready to murder you get into
Baton Rouge huge murder per capita New
Orleans been killing forever ever also a
lot of masks if you're gonna fight
people you want to find it without
identities new orleans a.k.a mass yeah
every other is a reason to wear a mask
nick what do you have just the lineup of
rappers alone from louisiana mystical in
jail just juvenile released Lil Wayne
wanted and mr. boozy badass o boosie
badazz
boy he's bad
you can't stop boost it's too cool he
just got out of here with back went back
in and there's on like a pretty horrific
crime that got him in there in the first
place yeah yeah he's caught up in the
Dark Arts brother yeah man Boosie bang
bang banner and I and Bootsie got nine
kids man yeah miss hatch that's his
mother and she teaches a school over
there but world or my brother lives you
know your brother over in Texas highest
what is it called death row executions
yeah when Bush was in office so they're
not afraid to kill and they don't give a
[ __ ] if you're innocent or guilty light
him up son light him up I don't move
okay see ya
ya have a bad day yeah yet a long day
dude whatever bro go to heaven you know
what I'm saying tell God about it I
don't want to hear this story
Jesus Christ yeah a bad day man I was a
tough one
are you gonna go with your heart because
you're from there your heart and soul
man or are you gonna go with what Google
has to offer which is the higher stats
and that's Texas I love Texas I think it
is a while we go with football teams
okay I am got the Longhorns the
Longhorns you got LSU LSU that's our
main one
well they got Shaq Shaq came out of
there Shaq out of Texas you have
LaMarcus Aldridge came out of there you
got a major Applewhite he didn't do
anything LSD a big baby big baby Davis
who actually lives right across the
street over Dolph Jefferson I tried to
get him in here man I don't know man
Texas god this is tough brewing bruh you
know what brother on this one man you
just ate with Texas on it I just love
Texas I'm gonna have to go with
Louisiana because I see why I hate
Louisiana yeah no he's fine to tell you
no you're not uh I knew it you would be
if you were you'd be um who's Bert
Kreischer friend the comedian Tom Segura
if you hated Louisiana be Tom Segura
really yeah let me tell you what
happened to me when I did be memorized
it'd be oh yeah I remember you left at
the end I was in my room and I bought a
clipper set to I was gonna shave my head
okay and you know those clipper sets are
like airtight you can't open those you
can't even have have scissors it's hard
open I don't have anything but they had
a corkscrew in the [ __ ] bucket this
is in New Orleans
I took horse crew ripped it stabbed
myself little tiny hole that's awesome
guess what happened what whole [ __ ]
arm turned brown
gang had to get it drained my elbows
swelled up to the like a [ __ ] bowling
ball
Gangrel on the base on a base in Korea
on Korea cuz it was like a week later I
was in Korea yeah and they had to drain
all this fluid out it was from New
Orleans that's a dirty [ __ ] City miss
that swamp on baby you don't know say I
got swamp arm dude a dog Mikey you turn
into a cat brush that kind of City I was
meowing and I was eating warm milk yeah
it wasn't my mother some milk some were
left out by their [ __ ] oh that's extra
milk yeah it sound like a lucky guy yeah
what I'm saying is this man it would be
wrong for me not to go from the state
where I [ __ ] started root I will have
to go with Louisiana I'm going with
Texas what do what do the people say
come on Texas have a bad day tell Jesus
about el Jesus about a Texas also if
we're going by the sheer volume of
submissions from people from Texas it
was like two to one Texas first
everything else they were very proud and
excited to fight it you know what just
do this think of it this way because I
know you're sad and I know your heart is
bleeding right now cuz that his soul is
but think about it this way like what
how many listeners and fans you have in
Texas you know I mean they just came out
they came out and they let you know 80%
bro no welcome your hometown give two
shits about your show yeah two shits
about your show it is pretty sad
that's sad my mom said she voted a
couple times yeah and she only have a
phone so I don't think she did probably
called a nurse yeah I don't think the
voting says anything about the people
from Louisiana cuz they won like 92 10
in the first round it's just the
strength of Texas yeah Texas a strong
man stroma Texas strong I don't it is it
is now well that's uh that's two
brackets man I think we'll stop there
and we may have next week we'll have
somebody do do what if we get Glen big
baby Davis to come in and do one of the
rounds with us that would be that would
be awesome I love that he might be sad
that Louisiana's out I will say we have
dr. Perlmutter next week and
maybe with Nate bargatze oh yeah maybe
with Nate bargatze I could do some air
right there that'd be fun to do that
yeah because we got Perlmutter next week
huh mm-hmm but then how we gonna do to
skip on this uh the basketball March
Madness doesn't end in March either I
think we can bleed this into April okay
cool man wow that was fun was it fun I
had fun man it was awesome you're a
brilliant man we had a blast dude Nikki
did a great job man thanks you really
did a great job putting this together
this is this is a blast this is cool
just seeing people interact with it too
I think that's brilliant yeah so cool
they're really into this Nick did a lot
of work man he did a really good job
yeah maybe we'll package up all the
submissions and we'll put him on our
Clips channel cuz I mean so many people
submitted it was they love this I'm
actually it actually scares me we might
be headed for work I don't know yeah
people are excited man people want their
States I feel like there's too much of
this national stuff where people are
talking for everyone yeah and enough
voice voices from a lot of places aren't
getting heard yeah and other voices are
getting heard because those voices own
like a lot of the electronic equipment
and a lot of the airwaves time to speak
up yeah a little city I think people are
man you know so it's interesting how did
Washington State do they won or they got
a bye in the first round because of
population and they got Utah next so
they got to face them follow the Mormons
and the Tongans yep and next round our
matchups we have Ohio and Iowa Michigan
verse Kentucky Indiana Minnesota
Illinois verse South Dakota Nick and in
the West we have Arizona versus New
Mexico Washington versus Utah Colorado
versus the 13 seed Montana I think that
might be our Cinderella team the louis
sita still still left and then
california versa Laska that's a fun
matchup
who's your dark horse over there
Channing I think's gonna win the whole
thing I'm gonna yeah I'm not in the
whole entire just your Dark Horse who's
like who's your underdog right now
that's still out there that's got a shot
my underdog I think I'm definitely gonna
go with Alaska Wow yeah yeah I was gonna
say the same thing that's crazy you
think the same way man if you live in
Alaska you're [ __ ] crazy yeah you're
crazy it's cold as [ __ ] you only get an
hour's worth of sunlight
kidding me they wanna fight just they
don't want to fight for two reasons one
to warm my in and two to [ __ ] die
yeah a rather just die
let me just die [ __ ] it I was gonna die
anyways money will go out when your
mother got with a warm wallet in my
chest
yeah it's always dark anyways might as
well shut my eyes forever they're
fighting for light bro and that's a
whole different the whole eternal light
yeah get the [ __ ] out of here
jo koy man thank you so much for being
here with us today and being a part of
this do this is cool bro yeah I'm a huge
fan here's man you're one of the
hardest-working guys and you've always
been you know just I mean uh just a
light man you always are so positive and
it's infectious bro thank you happy to
know you man you're killing the game man
well you're making people reach and I
love that we're doing what we can is all
about man you see levels and you want to
reach those levels and you're making
people reach that level so thank you so
no no I'm getting inspired by you right
now gang gang man I'll see you on the
scene the war let's go and we do an
intro and we'll put in all your plugs
and stuff what you got coming up that's
awesome yeah love you man
[Music]
but when I reach that round I'll share
this peace of mind I found I can defeat
it in my bones
thought it's gonna take
little time for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself on my
[Music]
you